when professor whittie one of the
world's biggest female celebrities nicki
minaj has today publicly linked the
coronal arts vaccines to impotence now
she's got eight million followers on
twitter many of them are young people
the young people you're suggesting
should get vaccinated what would you say
to them and how concerned are you by
public comments like that from public
figures um prime minister sage and spyen
have both advised that the government
that working from home is one of the
single most effective measures of
reducing transmission but looking at
your autumn and winter plan it's not
actually part of plan b it seems to kind
of hover as some kind of plan c with a
decision on its shelf for a later date
when we actually look at the document
why are you more reticent about
deploying working from home to combat
this and one last question um prime
minister a lot of your cabinet are
feeling very anxious as we're gathered
here today about their own futures can
you formally rule out a reshuffle ahead
of the conservative party conference
chris
on the reshuffle
thank you prime minister um uh so there
are a number of myths that fly around
with varying some of which are just
clearly ridiculous and some of which are
clearly designed just to scare that
happens to be one of them that is untrue
uh i my own strong suggestion if i may
to uh
media present and not present is
repeating them in public actually just
gives some credence which they don't
need
they're untrue full stop uh if you think
about where we are actually overall and
this is this is a slightly longer answer
to your question i think it's a very
important one the great majority people
are getting vaccinated
so the great majority people are
ignoring these myths
and if you talk about people in their
50s and 60s and 70s you're talking about
over 90 people getting vaccinated uh and
very few people actually are actively in
this in a sense in the anti-vaxx group
there are a group of people who've got
strange beliefs and fine and they make
their own choices and in a sense also
fine people are adults are allowed to
make their own choices however strange
that is a basic principle of
medical ethics actually
but there are also people who go around
trying to discourage other people from
taking
a vaccine which could be life-saving or
prevent them from having life-changing
uh
injuries to themselves
and many of those people i regret to say
i think know that they are peddling
untruths
but they still do it
in my view they should be ashamed
and i'll leave it at that
and i look
just on that steve i'm not familiar with
the works of uh or not as familiar with
the works of nicki minaj as i probably
should be but i am familiar with with uh
nikki kanani a superstar gp of bexley
who's appeared many times on uh before
you uh who who will tell you that
vaccines are wonderful and everybody
should get them uh so i prefer to listen
to to nikki kanani and on your point
about about working from home this is
this is one of those things where i
think just look at what the public are
doing i think people are coming back to
their their offices that you're seeing
the numbers the numbers that the time uh
really suggests that people are uh more
confident uh they're getting back into
their their places of work for the
reasons i've given many times before i
think that that's a good thing i think
that uh on the whole uh
particularly for younger people uh you
need the social capital you get from uh
the workplace you need the the learning
from uh from colleagues i i think that
will on the whole be uh be more
productive and and it's fairer to to
everybody if we can if we can do that
but people are also doing are being
sensible and um responsible uh if we
have to change the the guidance that we
uh that we give on on that then uh then
we will but that's that's plan b as uh
as you as you'll have uh you've heard
earlier on
that's the problem i mean the point
about something like working from home
it's about contact patterns and and in a
way this is all quite straightforward
that disease spreads much more rapidly
the more contacts we have and in certain
environments the more contacts you have
are more risky and working from home is
just a way in which contacts inevitably
go down so that's why it was highlighted
as a particularly effective
measure to decrease spread at times when
you have big increases in in levels